[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein leckeres spargel
rezept endlich gibt es ja den ersten
spargel monate nicht wir waren neulich
im speicher und haben was richtig
leckeres gegessen und zwar einen warmen
spargelsalat mit kartoffeln also so
kartoffeln spargel salat und darüber
dann so ein gebratenes lachsfilet das
mache ich jetzt heute für euch nach die
zutaten sind super einfach für den
warmen kartoffelsalat verwende ich 600
gramm kartoffeln da zähle ich das
gestellte gewicht 500 gramm spargel weiß
und grün eine normale zwiebel eine rote
zwiebel etwas sonnenblumenöl und
weißweinessig zwei teelöffel senf
gemüsebrühe salz und pfeffer die
kartoffeln habe ich jetzt bereits
geschält jetzt schreibe ich dir einfach
in würfel so etwa zwei bis drei
zentimeter groß aber er zwei eher klein
das salat der war richtig schön mit
gemüsebrühe an gemacht und es war
einfach ein richtig schönes leckeres
gericht gerade für warme tage geht
superschnell und ich meine wir uns doch
einfach nur gegessen aber ich denke so
wie ich es mache wird er wahrscheinlich
zubereitet sein
zumindest werde hoffentlich genauso
schmecken murat darf man also probieren
jetzt die kartoffeln direkt auf den herd
stellen mit etwas salz etwas so ein
teelöffel salz und schon mal das wasser
an machen zum kochen wie kartoffeln
brauchen wir jetzt gar nicht so lange
weil sie eben auch klein geschnitten
sind jetzt kann ich schon mal den
spargel schälen
da stehe ich jetzt natürlich nur den
weißen spargel den kojen muss man nicht
schälen
da waren wir heute morgen noch schnell
bei unseren bauern wir haben nämlich den
bauern klaus der klaus schröter aus
reilingen
da holen wir uns in spanien ganz frisch
umfeld sozusagen damit jeden tag
geerntet und jeden tag verkauft
finde ich echt krass
die spargelzeit muss man echt immer
ausnutzen
falls ihr ausländer kommt aus der
umgebung wo wir wohnen also im raum
mannheim karlsruhe heidelberg da könnt
ihr euch mal beim bauern schröder
vorbeigucken aber mit sicherheit gibt es
auch bei euch in der region an bauern
und nicht finde man sollte die bauern
auf jeden fall unterstützen jetzt hinten
einfach schräg anschneiden holzig sind
nicht weil der spargel einfach von heute
morgen ist ganz frisch und jetzt ganz
dünne scheiben schneiden
es sieht so diagonal geschnitten recht
am schönsten auf die kurz vor dem kopf
fürchten auf der spargel kopf der blood
menschen ganzen
und den grünen spargel den muss man
nicht schälen außer unten vernehme ich
manchmal sowie die holzigen enden weg
und den rest macht sich daran und
schneiden auch schön find ich habe jetzt
die kartoffeln 5 minuten kochen lassen
sie haben jetzt noch ein bisschen bis
aber passt perfekt denn jetzt kommt der
spargel einfach noch dazu für etwa ein
bis zwei minuten da darf ruhig noch ein
bisschen kinder haben also nicht
verkochen einmal zwei minuten stellen
und ich hab jetzt auch schon die
zwiebeln fein geschnitten und voran
natürlich geschält und kann dies hier in
der planer noch anbraten ist öl dazu das
ist das essen nicht verwechseln und die
zwiebeln einfach so ein bisschen drin
braten damit so schön glasig werden und
die röstaromen gekommen das finde ich
immer ganz lecker im kartoffelsalat und
den sud aus den kartoffeln und dem
spargel denen nicht wegschütten denken
da echt ganz gut benutzen für eine
spargelsuppe denn dann ist da schon die
stärke darin aus den kartoffeln und dann
ist echt lecker das morgen bei uns
starker druck
da
ich sagte brühe aufheben und jetzt noch
warm noch heiß mit der brühe übergießen
also mit der gemüsebrühe kann natürlich
auch kartoffeln und den spargel direkt
in gemüsebrühe kochen
aber ich gebe es jetzt danach dazu denn
ich möchte dass das ganze auch noch ein
bissel wie so eine soße daran haften
bleibt es gibt einfach kurz ziehen
lassen selbst kann auch noch dazu dem es
sich noch dazu geben und durchziehen
lassen
jetzt sind die zwiebeln auch soweit und
ich gebe sie jetzt hier zum salat und
die pfanne habe ich jetzt extra groß
gewählt denn da wird es dann gebraten
und beim lachs könnte jetzt entweder
frischen lachs nehmen oder einfach
gefrorenen das geht auch damals keine
frischen lachs bekommt ich habe ihn an
der fischtheke gekriegt tag gibt's immer
frischen lachs aber ansonsten geht auch
der gefrorene und lachs hat er wirklich
genügend eigenes wetter hat nämlich dass
kein fett mehr dazu jetzt auf mittel
hoher hitze zuerst auf der fleisch seite
also auf der seite ohne haut schön
anbraten für etwa drei bis vier minuten
ganz langsam und da ist ganz wichtig
dass man eben eine beschichtete pfanne
nimmt weil fisch einfach ziemlich zart
ist und wenn so umgeschichtet bleibt
euch alles hängen und dann hat man von
jolie eigentlich nichts mehr in fisch
immer erst dann wenden wenn unten schon
eine kruste ist hier am rand sieht man
auch schon was auch schön langsam
durchgang
den salat schmeckt jetzt noch mal auch
mit salz und pfeffer vorher natürlich
probieren denn meine gemüsebrühe diva
gesalzen kurz durch gehören und ruhig
eben auch mit dieser brühe servieren
dann nehme ich einfach einen tiefen
teller
gerne so ein bisschen pflücksalat drauf
dann noch ein paar sprossen dazu und
dann lege ich jetzt den fisch gleich
darauf noch im warmen zustand wirklich
so in 15 bis 20 minuten gericht ist
schneller mittagessen so alle fragen
sich jetzt wo der murat hat sich aber
verändert ja ich habe ihm gesagt er hat
vom probieren
ich habe extra weg geschickt damit ich
probieren kann ich will gerne mit einer
küche super jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ich probier mal den den lachs
sehr lecker sehr knusprig und als
beilage haben wir hier kartoffeln mit
salat ja auch gelesen
spargelsalat seine mama spargel
kartoffelsalat schmeckt sehr gut also
dass ist mit nun ja ich habe noch ein
einziges foto
also ich verabschiede mich dann wieder
okay
schmeckt sehr gut was schönes leichte
und wie gesagt super schnell ja der
murat cicek probieren können aber die
anderen fraktionen zu verhalten hat
selber aber salat isst dann doch dafür
schaffe ich auch noch wenn er liegt in
der stadt spielt aber auch noch mal ein
fischer falls ihr das rezept nach macht
damit verlinkt mich gerne auf euren
fotos wie gesagt probiert gerne mal aus
wenn ihr keinen fisch dazu mögt dann
könnt ihr natürlich auch das ganze ist
so es nicht so ist der weg an den ball
kommt was wir haben wollen kann oder ihr
könnt auch hinten dazu machen was ihr
möchtet aber mit dem lachs finde ich das
schon richtig lecker also viel spaß beim
nachmachen
danke klaus mit den leckeren spargel
[Musik]